this one comes from professor edward lee
of berkeley i love david how your work
has complicated the faith many
scientists hold in an ultimately
deterministic world i was wondering
whether you've looked at john norton so
we talked about that
so we actually did talk about that in
particular why is this example
controversial why are so many people
offended by the idea of uncaused action
yeah i've also encountered uh professor
lee's work and i find also
mutual admiration here um that i am
impressed with a lot of his work
um this is actually a subtle thing i'm
very careful in my
stuff on inference devices
there is no laws discussed mentioned
anyway there's no rules
there's no
mathematicalization of the patterns in
the underlying reality
it's just
world lines in a set
and an
observer
is one particular
subset of those world lines something
it's observing is another subset
what it means to observe
has to do with the relationship between
those two subsets
what it would mean to make predictions
would then be another subset
and basically by means of these subsets
and their overlaps that this topology
you would build up the structure of a
scientist using theories to make
predictions
about what might occur in the world and
those theories are going to be in the
form of rules and laws
and so for example max tegmark's
multiverse work i highly plug his um
foundations of physics paper
in the earlier animals of physics um
papers
on the multiverse don't bother with pop
books go to go for the real me
um
in that work he ultimately
reduces the notion of physical reality
to a set of laws to a set of
mathematical
rules
and the presumption that all physical
reality is is just a set of rules which
is
precisely why
john norton's example is controversial
because it seems to
wreak havoc with the notion that
physical reality can be reduced to a set
of rules
that's i think ultimately from a
sociological point of view why people
are upset about that
i'm very careful in my work that rules
don't appear there's just subsets
there's a topology there might be
patterns those patterns can be violated
at any point in time
no free lunch
newton's laws even if they are there
they might just suddenly disappear
tomorrow before the
before
the ball of john norton has even had a
chance to try to think about falling off
of the dome
but many people instead want to
implicitly
they think of a mathematical universe as
being
a set of things like differential
equations
rules laws
and i just think of it instead as being
a set and there can be a topology on
that set
and the topology might have patterns
which you might be able to embody as
such rules and laws
or it might not
it all just depends on the topology and
different topologies are going to either
be rule like or not rule-like law-like
or not law like
and it's not even the case that one is
real and one is not real they're just
all different realities
it's legitimate to want it as legitimate
as one another there's no privileged
reality
i
i suspect that
all of these kinds of answers i'm giving
you these questions
are not necessarily fully fruitful it's
kind of
as an aside as an interviewee to give a
answer to a question in a stand-alone
manner rather than in a dialogue
where i can see the response of the
questioner and therefore refine my
answer
accordingly it's kind of a strange thing
because it's almost like open loop
rather than closed loop control
um but in any case um i hope that
answers a little bit um a professor
lee's question
professor thank you so much for spending
so much time with me and the audience
i'm sure thanks you too
okay well thanks very much sorry if i
was too much open loop control i think
it was a little bit logarithmic today
but
so uh thank you very very much
and if you could give me the information
about um the forum for this so i can
then forward that to the s5 people and
kevin contact me
great okay okay goodbye professor thank
you okay truly it was a blast like i'm
great to be speaking to someone who also
is philosophically inclined even though
you had your excoriations on philosophy
you still had your philosophy of
philosophy
yeah in many ways yes
i think philosophy is almost by
definition the most important
intellectual endeavor there is but and
this is being a real snide [ __ ]
i don't i think it's really unfortunate
people that actually engage in it
have not been trained
properly and that's most of philosophers
um it's unfortunately exceptions um you
know dan dan i think
the training can either be explicitly or
implicitly and i think dan is an example
of somebody who's quote trained well to
be really speaking in snotty asinine
terms
um but yeah i think it's the most
important um subject there is
almost by definition